suite aux déclarations du président
concernant les artistes
je trouverais bien intéressant qu'il y
ait une forme de sondage consulter les
artistes qu'ils fassent des propositions
de ce qu'ils ont déjà mis en place de ce
qui existe de ce qui est faisable et ce
qui est réalisable par exemple les
actions qui sont déjà menées depuis bien
longtemps sur fort de france j'en veux
pour preuve les actions menées par
daniel betis josé louis d'autres encore
dans le milieu scolaire dans le temps
scolaire en temps scolaire et il existe
aujourd'hui par exemple l'association
martinique images que je dirige qui mène
des actions dans le milieu scolaire et
ce sont des choses à conforter à
consolider pour que ça puisse
fonctionner donc pourquoi pas